[Music]
I hope you enjoyed watching the
highlights of the award ceremony without
further Ado it is my pleasure to invite
Miss Don Lim executive director of the
design Singapore Council to give her
welcome remarks Don
please
hi good afternoon everyone and thank you
for spending your Friday afternoon with
us uh and also for not taking the long
weekend out of Singapore and then being
here today so really appreciate your
time uh I thought the video actually did
a wonderful job introducing the
recipient so that least very little for
me to say more uh but I thought just a
little experience I had um I was just
sharing with a Yori colleagues just now
U they're so lucky that Maxwell Food
Center just across the streets so just
before coming here I I took a quick uh
lunch break uh incidentally two tourists
uh shared the table with me so me being
the very gapo Singapore and I was like
hey are you visiting what have you seen
did you go to the city Gallery across
the street uh and and throughout that
conversation one of the things that came
up um is that Singapore is so unique
because we are a city in a garden and
that whole
intentionality of building green into
every aspect of our lives in a very
dense Urban environment uh is core to
our ethos and our design um identity as
a nation and as a city uh and four of
the recipients are with us today of this
year's eight and three of them the works
that they will share with you today
speak a lot about that ethos that we
stand for as a city in a garden right
from from Lenard and The Man Behind the
face of many of our public parks uh for
which my dog and myself are are very
happy recipients we spent whole time in
those Parks right um to the W uh W the
the mines behind the Singapore Pavilion
uh at the Expo 2020 right which also
reflects that Singapore ethos we took
overseas and showed the world what that
looks like for us right and we have sura
studio with Anton where they took that
Singapore ethos to Jakarta and
rejuvenated uh a park that was diminish
in that was degenerating and they
rejuvenated that and gave a new lease of
life in the middle of a very dense and
bustling City so there's something here
that the Singapore design ethos stands
for that green that biodiversity but the
ability for us to live together in the
city with nature now on that topic of
Rejuvenation though we have uh hansan
Studio which I took the whole topic
Rejuvenation on a different level and I
had the privilege of uh visiting the
showcase at the VNA uh which was the
first time we did a cross Atlantic I
suppose uh CrossCountry uh creative
partnership uh with a very well-known
design Museum uh in the UK and uh Hans
uh and his uh cohort of
designers took broken objects from the
UK and from Singapore and breathed a new
lease of Life in in them and in that
process gave it a different meaning and
a different value uh to what the object
originally was one of my favorite ones
that I saw and if you have a chance to
take a look at some of the pictures I
hope he'll share some of it later um uh
someone from the public had contributed
a little penguin figurine that had lost
a wing so it was a broken winged penguin
uh and Hans had gotten one of the
designers to look at how to create
create a new value for that broken item
and what came up was the penguin had a
new Wing through retan weaving it was a
retan wing and you can only give that
with a designer's lens with a cultural
uh identity from Singapore and so for
the rest of this afternoon I hope you
enjoy the stories that the four of them
will share with you uh and through that
I hope you'll be inspired also in your
own design Journey uh and continue to
fly the Singapore flag high in design
thank you
[Applause]
thank you Don ladies and gentlemen the
panel today will discuss the topic
designing for a sustainable World
designing for a more inclusive and
sustainable future may sound like a
lofty ambition for a small nation like
Singapore but homegrown design Solutions
can have can have a place on the world
map of best design practices the first
Speaker representing PDA 2023 design of
the Year Singapore Pavilion Expo 202 20
Dubai is architect pu hongway director
at warha Architects private limited
hongway graduated with a master of
architecture from National University of
Singapore and joined warha in 2006 he
sees design as an optimistic
intervention to maximize potential and
catalyze positive change he's interested
in a nature-driven approach to
architecture and urbanism complementing
his professional work hway is a
certified ISO auditor green Mark
accredited professional and Universal
Design assessor and has served in the
National Library board and impa's design
advisory committees on accessibility and
skyrise Greenery he was featured in ur's
third edition of the 20 under 45
exhibition in 2017 which presented The
Works of 20 emerging Architects under
the age of
45 hung was involved in several
award-winning projects such as oasia
Hotel downtown enabling Village and the
Singapore Pavilion at Expo 2020 Dubai he
is also the architect responsible for
the pan-pacific orchard hotel and is
currently working on the NS Square
enabling and enabling Village extension
let's welcome hongway to share more
about the Singapore Pavilion Expo 2020
Dubai project thank
you right um good afternoon our
appreciation to the judging panel and
the organizers for according this uh
award to the Pavilion um Expo is one of
a kind it happens every 5 years it's a
microcosm of the world it brings country
together in one place and of course Expo
2020 was made more eventful with
covid well the countries were not on the
same boat we were all in the same storm
so on behalf we like to acknowledge and
thank everyone in the Singapore and
Dubai team for where Gathering the storm
together well the pavillon is no longer
around but our hope is that through
through it we have seed some optimism
and and hope for a better future that
values
nature so since its beginning all the
way back in 1851 Expo has always been a
experi exper experimental view that uh
enriches the world it brought to the
world Innovations and inventions in food
like ketchup instant coffee to
technology like telephone typewriter
touchscreen and Expo 2020 looks at the
future the future of our lives our city
our
Earth the master plan is organized
around a Central Plaza the aasa plaza
with loops to three thematic District
the opportunity District District in
yellow the mobility District in blue and
the sustainable District in green and
Singapore is located here at the
sustainable
district and Singapore is among almost
200 exhibitors in this Warfare and of
course we ask ourselves why visit the
Singapore pavillon and how can Singapore
stand
out so as a small country Singapore is
connected is both connected and affected
by the world the world gravels with
issues like climate change loss of
biodiversity population growth rapid
urbanization so these are all issues of
global urgencies and currency and we
have come to known Singapore as a city
in nature with uh emphasis on livability
and sustainability so Expo 2020 was a
unique opportun Unity to share with the
world how Singapore is tackling this uh
complex issues through planning through
design through Innovations so we ask how
is Singapore a city in nature how do we
showcase Singapore in a desert and how
does Singapore design for a better
future this was a photo of the site uh
taken in November
20119 uh it's taken below a sheltered
linkway that connects all the pavill
as you can see it was harsh it was
Barren it was really
hot and this was the photo of the site
of the Pavilion uh one year later in
October
2021 is taken in front of the sheltered
linkway and what we have done here was
we created an oasis in the
desert we wanted the pavillon to be an
escape from the hustle and bustle of the
Expo where visitors are instinctively
drawn on to
Nature and we wanted the pavillon to be
open to be porous to be inviting it
brings visitors on a experiential
journey through a
three-dimensional Garden I will bring
you through the layers in the next few
slides at the start visitors walk into a
large ground Garden a respite from the
surroundings Key Programs are and touch
points are house within three green
cones moving from cone to Cone visitors
will have moments of relief with the lar
Greenery an elevated canopy walk weaves
the journey together along the parameter
around through the cones and up the 9 m
space we wanted to create a stroll in a
park a hanging garden hangs above the
cone and the journey accumulates at the
Sky Market it is a open plan deck for
Gatherings and
events and last but not least uh we kept
the pavillon with a solar canopy with
some pipes that maximize solar energy
and
daylighting so we open on 1 October 2021
almost a year after the original opening
due to
covid at this entry visitors are engaged
by the different layers of greenery both
in front as well as above the phyto
remediation pond in front creates a calm
mirrored surface that reflects and
mirror and multiplies The Greenery we
have three cones the rainforest cone
City cone and the flower cone all lined
up along the center surrounded by
Forest once in visitors are surrounded
by Nature three-dimensionally the PS
meanders between a thick green Edge and
the green cones with the canopy walk
zipping overhead and visitors are
ushered into the City Coin uh first for
a multimedia show the form of the cone
presents a
360° canvas for an immersive surround
experience
inside the show is directed by Brian
Kong our local Brian Kong it show CH the
visitors um through the world we want to
we are in and the world we want to be
in after which the visitors Journey up
the canopy
walk along the parameter to taking the
sights and sounds we created Lookouts
for Vantage points and these Vantage
points are coed by m fence these fence
uh combined with the shade and Greenery
lowers the perceived temperature by 5 to
10° compared to the outside temperature
making it comfortable for visitors even
without air
conditioning next um we brought the
visitors through the three cones in
series um visitors first encountered the
rainforest
cone uh which showcases tropical plants
on the walls it emphasizes our Singapore
effort and drive to conserve our nature
and to extend its footprint
vertically then the visitors cut through
the city cone in the center before
walking into the flower
cone the flower cone is where our
national flower is on vibrant display
four
terraniums are set against a wall with
more than 50 native orid species whose
colors are accentuated by a play of
light the terranium shows Singapore's
Innovation to propagate and to populate
native species disase in our
cities and outside visitors will see
tracks curing around the
cones these are for Prototype climbing
robots equipped with cameras and sensors
that monitor the health of the plants
collect the data such as humidity oxygen
level so with the information collected
the amount of Water and Light can be
calibrated visitors mix it back to the
rainforest cone walking up a spiral with
a kinetic Taro cup outwork spinning
downwards in the center the sky Market
is a open sided Deck with the top of the
Tre cones as a series of notes at the
center we have the Red Dot for events
that's fled by pantries serving local
food and sanen arena is located above
the flower
cone the arena is a multiple space it's
a gathering space for programs for
events it's also Amphitheater for
Singapore mid
shows visitors takes the stairs down to
the Galleria where specially created
pieces that illustrate our local
creativity and culture on display
together with the stories of the artists
the makers and
entrepreneurs and we wanted to end the
journey the journey with some fun um
salad dressing here created an
interactive game digital nature which
simulates a virtual Utopia where players
play to Nature Nature true playing uh it
shares the workings of the Pavilion it's
a reminder for the visitors especially
kids on how they are individual actions
have on the collective outcome of the
environment three times every evening
visitors are treated to a light show
with a soundscape composed by our local
Don Richmond
the lighting accentuates the Pavilion
forms and Landscape presenting a
different experience at
night this photo here was taken a month
about a month just before opening
outside it was looking all lar and
Serene but trust me inside there was a
lot of activities trying to complete the
finishing touch to ready The Pavilion to
welcome the
visitors and since opening the reception
to the Pavilion has been really positive
the Singapore Pavilion had more than a
million visitors all interested in
knowing how a sustainable Oasis in a
desert can be created and how nature can
nurture the
future and Singapore pavillon is
recognized as one of the greenest
pavillon at the
Expo more than 50% of the ground is
planted overall it achieves 170% green
replacement and Beyond The Greenery The
Pavilion is a water and energy machine
achieving 100% water and energy
self-sufficiency and treating 100% of
its organic output through a
biodigester and the local media picked
up the Ambitions of uh The Pavilion it
shows that there must be stewardship and
responsibility in the design of our bu
environment encountering climate
change and more so the Pavilion also
brings together the depth and breadth of
the Singapore DNA and brands in the use
of the building material food that serve
the merchandise the videos and the
stories so beyond the greenery the
pavillon is transformative in its
working all its energy used for
desination for lighting for irrigations
for fans are all predetermined
calibrated and monitored we have more
than 500 solar panels that supply enough
energy for the 6 months duration of the
Expo it's designed to be
self-sufficient did it all go according
to plan no there were days of sand storm
where the sand blanket the PV panels in
the plants and clock the irrigation we
have to host and blow them off and fix
them but these are irregularities and
spikes on good days and weeks um the
system
works every Photon that we collected is
not wasted part of the energy harnessed
from the solar canopy Powers the glow
lights under the shade to promote plant
growth and
photosynthesis water is SC as part of
the water conservation effort water is
drawn from the ground powered by solar
energy desalinated on site and
distributed and likewise every drop is
not wasted water is optimized in the
sustenance in the operation of the
Pavilion and water is experienced
through the Mis fans and water features
together the blue and the green helps to
increase immunity and the thermal
comfort of the within the
Pavilion this photo shows a thermal
sensor shooting at the spot just along
the edge on the left and on the green
wall on the right the ambient
temperature there was 42° C the shter
area was 36 the green wall is 29 so
standing there you can feel the
difference the Singapore Pavilion
demonstrated that a self- sustaining
Oasis in the desert is possible and
together with it a thriving nature would
invite biod biodiversity we had a local
dove then sting at the
entrance um two eggs were hatched and
they became additional touch point and
attraction as part of the
journey and to give context to the
visitors as well as the locals we
compared the ecosystem Services of the
Pavilion against um local typologies and
we postulate what if Dubai have many
Singapore Pavilion many Oasis it points
to a different future that is nurtured
by
Nature I'd like to end off with um the
future we choose will depend will
require us to pay attention to our bond
with nature and Singapore pavillon
shares with the world that Singapore is
shaping a different future with our
built environment one that is nurtured
by nature one that is resilient and
regenerative and we definitely look
towards a better future yeah has been an
honor for the team thank
[Applause]
you thank you hungi for the insightful
sharing next we have design of the Year
Tibet Eco Park representing Tibet Eco
Park is Mr Anton s director at s studio
private limited Anton is an accredited
landscape architect and principal of C
Studio throughout his design career
Anton has played a major role in Urban
Design and Landscape architecture
projects across Singapore Indonesia and
Beyond prior to establishing s studio he
played a key role in the design process
of numerous award-winning projects such
as the Pongo prominade padari Park and
Kong admiralty Anton has also taught at
land landscape architecture design
students at the nanyang Academy of Fine
Arts and the National University of
Singapore andon
pleas
[Applause]
thank you for the introduction and first
of all I I would like to congratulate
for the organizers to arrange these
beautiful Awards uh for me is a very
significant milestone for our practice
and also congratulate to all the
recipients this year we have eight uh
award recipients four is architectural
and four is non-architectural design uh
for General design and I notice through
my preparation of my presentation today
not is there's a shared common trade for
the design of the year for the
non-architectural category this about
reinventions and uh reinvention is
really about the art of turning
adversity into opportunity setbacks into
comebacks so you know if you want to win
the next year
Awards this is the one of the
tips and T eopa is the uh reinvention of
the haare is really
about um finding um hacking the IKEA
furniture into a demena friendly uh
object and R for repair I think Hans
will explain ler how to turn a ordinary
object into a artworks if I I if I say
it like that and the t eopa is the same
it's about reinvent about the park that
has been neglected for many years this
was the condition prior to the raliz the
P has been damaged there's a canals and
it's pared by the main road with a High
traffics but they have a very beautiful
trees uh this is the condition when we
visited that the pathway has been
degraded damage the trees some is good
condition some is bad conditions and in
15 months we manage to transform this
partk into a um something that Beyond
expectation we never imagine that uh it
become viral everyone in Jakarta and
Beyond Jakarta want to visit this park
this was taken a few weeks after the
Park opening 60,000 people come into
this park equivalent to attending a
cplay concert
probably so even they know it's super
crowded and it's difficult to find
parking space they have to find parking
maybe one to two kilometer away from the
park but they still want to come so this
is Jakarta I would like to
explain why why people want to come here
what make this part so attracting and
how do we do that and this has been done
during the covid time period in 15
months five months design8 months
construction two months for tender so
something that is really speed up in of
process design thinking and the design
decision everything so there's a five
chapters five chapters that I'm going to
present is chapter one is about the
context Jakarta has been reducing the
green area significantly through the
years now is less than 10% I think
Singapore is much more than that the
size of the Jakarta is similar to
Singapore almost 700 kilomet square but
the population is double to Singapore
11.2 kilom so imagine double a
population less Greenery what kind of
life you can have in Jakarta every day
is really about struggle in traffic jam
urbanization because Indonesia have a 30
Province everyone want to work in
Jakarta from from uh from the village to
the University graduate they all come
and stay in Jakarta and this cause
flooding is the main issue in Jakarta
the Water
Sanitation uh uh social issue pollution
because as there are more people coming
to Jakarta to stay there the the city
become degraded and the most crucial
issue is the social
inclusivity if you go to jagat maybe you
see a nice Road big towers but if you go
deeper to the residential area people
live in a campong this is the condition
the children don't have a space to play
they play in the road they celebrate
birthday in the road and they live in
the middle of big city so it's really
lacking of a social space for the
children and look at this picture almost
the entire island is brown color is a
roof PES right there's no not much green
area and luckily we have tber EOP Park
here that is Reserve at the Forest City
right at the belly button of
Jakarta it's a 7.3 hectare site so it's
considered a big green area for Jakarta
people and surrounded by the very high
density residential housing deployment
with apartment apartment office and
schools so we have three challenge to
deal with this park we deal with
multiple stakeholders just like in
Singapore we deal with a lot with uh
different agency in one projects we have
a environmental agency the part used to
be a garbage dumping site because they
don't there's not much space so the
residents around it throw the rabbis
into this part look at the piles and
there's a canal managed by the Water
Resource agency there's a road that's
separating the park and the sidewalk on
the perimeter and the City forest park
by the park agency the second is the
degraded infrastructure condition the
canal has a insufficient capacity broken
side drain incoming water has been
unfiltered going into the canal directly
and throw to the uh main reverse and all
the broken pathway and social issue at
the perimeter of the parks and because
of the lowly topography every 3 to 4
hours of continuous rain the part will
be flooded and it Dage the existing
infrastructures and the trees so our
design it is really how can we turn this
adversity into to the opportunity we
learn about the uh existing site as you
can see they have a straight drain they
have a straight pathway the part is
split by the road this was my initial
sketch how the first thing that we want
to repair is the river ecosystem turn
that stri drain into a Meandering
reverse create a
connectivity between the two parts and
the third one create a program that is
contextual to the landscape characters
and it turns out into a blue green
Sanctuary with a multiple Nots and
program for uh community and different
edge of people so this is the design to
protecting the trees creating a river
ecology maximize the path connectivity
and create this program for um different
use according to the landscape
characters we turn this concrete Canal
the concrete Canal was made from a
simple technique of uh mixture of
concrete and rocks and we turn it we
break the stone and use back the stone
as part of the bioengineering and
replant it with a reparan vegetation we
also do do the hydrology study where if
you look at the above image there was
the study prior to R
vitalization every 10 hours years of uh
rainfall events we be flooded the entire
partk we do the simulation if we
ruralized that widen the rivers
the flood plan become
reduced we turn the paive gray space
from the dry land that frequent flooded
become into Active blue green space they
become a place to watch Birds people can
act can have a activity around the
boardwalk and the playground next to
it so this was the impression that we
shown to the governors right by changing
the drain into a swells uh we we can
bring back flora and FAA and create more
a purposeful experience for people come
to the park to change this condition
walking with the site protect the trees
as smast as possible for example there's
a gas station former gas station over
there we turn it into a playground and
the river is ruralized and put the right
plant species around
[Music]
it and also subtle design intervention
we don't want to change too much we only
have five eight months of construction
so we work closely with what we have
retain the trees and inject the right uh
design at the ground floor level by
doing this approach we create we repair
the infrastructures and create a
multiple program for many
users in the implementation stage of
course we have to adapting with the ways
of works because this is the first time
they do the uh soal bioengineering Works
they never done this kind of scale of
project uh naturalistic kind of approach
so we have to adapt with the skill of
the worker with the side
condition and what we do is because of
the time constraint we want to reuse
everything that we took out as part of
the construction material so ident
identifying the right material such as
the reiver stone the broken path reuse
as a compacted pathway and use it as a
part of the gabian
wall the then do a replanting so that
because the concrete is removed and the
Rocks become loose so we can do a
planting so the result is like this just
within two or three months construction
we change the canal that used to be like
this become a driving
Nature by doing this we change the
mindset of avoiding reverse become
coming close to the
rivers from manmade intervention this is
the drain that come from the re
residential we create the island to
protect the trees and become a
constructed wet land and now there's a
lot of VES butterfly and uh many animals
that come to this small scale of fat
lands this is also the first time the
trees were survey by by the local aoris
there's no aoris in Jakarta so I have to
find the the right persons and they
managed to come up with 1,500 trees
identific identification Within one
months and this was done parallel when
we did a concept design survey concept
design at the same time and with that
reports we identify which tree that is
good we try to retain so the
architecture give way to the trees the
drop off giveway to the trees and the
trees that is unhealthy and po safety
risk we reuse that we walk with the
local Carpenters turn it into a
Furniture turn it into the playground
look at that
cats
so this is about working with time
constraint maximize the site resources
use the local people and build uh
recycle reuse upcycle and re reinvent
the material that used to be disposed we
reuse that as part of our design and the
design outcome is uh thriving Parks it
was open in April by the former Governor
Jakarta and his best wayen currently
he's a candidate for the president of
Indonesia and what interesting is the
visual identity of the logo it was
captured by the each zones of our design
and turn into the infinity loop like the
bridge and become part of the uh
branding of the parks for example when
we want the president design award this
is the way they announce the
award and it turns into a part of the
landscape object signage and pathway and
when when I come to
this to the park a day after the opening
7:00 the par used to be like that for
many years people just use the park
[Music]
intuitively and look at the playground I
hope the guy at the trampoline is
fine so a walk in the park journey is
really creating the pathway that immerse
into various zones there's about eight
or nine programs the first time they
come they with arrive at the eucalyptus
trees and enjoy the plaza look at the
greenery there's a for people to do uh
reading uh shed library and these are
thematic Gardens where we design a
simple swing and the parents can sit
down at a picnic bench and the bridge
that is connecting the two parks
um it immers into the existing Tre
canopies and the part has been been used
by the local school every morning you
can see the a lot of student come in and
enjoy the park they learn about the
nature they play at the parks and a lot
of people doing the jogging and and at
the top of the page it doesn't looks
like you walk in the middle of the uh
City or on the streets it feels like in
the forest walk of Singapore and there's
a fitness
Corners playground we create this giant
crocodile uh inspired by the means SW
in in swam means there's a crocodile and
various playground that designed locally
not by playground supplier we we even
work with the local Carpenters pewing
decks and this is inspired by the
Learning Forest create a hammock around
the trees the difference is used by the
[Music]
cat so we have a suspension
bridge uh
boardwalks uh then the r and we also
want to make the parks to be exciting at
night time so we use lighting at the
bridge and it is a very beautiful night
environment because at night the trees
was light up and everything become bread
and become a Tik Tock
spot so uh design inex we we make a
groundbreaking design achievement
turning the water become a flood planes
and changing the condition from from
the um flooded area into a detention
area and design for resiliency changing
the mindsets from uh water water was a
burden and now become a burden the kids
playing around the waters and planting a
lot of trees create a new ecosystem
attract a lot of biodiversity that come
into the parks and become a social space
that raise the quality of life of the
local community from all
backgrounds with that uh two months ago
so I visited the park again for a
filming with ABC gardening Australia and
we interview the local residents that
local people that come into the park
this is what they say space before that
actually the garden is just like you
know it's just like plantations and
flowers but now they're starting to
build the facilities that is pretty
familiar you know kids can play
everywhere and then children can explore
I mean that's a great concept especially
this Echo Park this is our first visit
and you think this is amazing yeah in
Jakarta not many parts like this
yeah to the mall where they can have
this kind of playground but now we can
go to this kind of park for free and
they can have that kind of playground as
well so as conclusion as designer we can
get a recognition from awards from
academics from fellow pro professional I
think the most important is the
recognition from the users because we
design for them and I think uh a good
design just simply makes uh people
happy thank
[Applause]
you thank you Anton for that very
inspiring sharing next for our last
design of the year project are for
repair we have Mr Hans tan founder of
hansan Studio Hans is a Designer maker
curator and associate professor at the
National University of Singapore
at his aonomus Studio Hans makes use of
beauty and utility as a pretext for
visual discourse tiptoeing the
boundaries between design craft and art
his work maintains a keen focus on
disrupting common things materials and
Fabrication processes embedding
narratives that poke at Collective
memory and comment on design and its
industry as a phenomenon especially in
the context of Heritage consumption and
waste as a curator Hans employs design
as a creative and generative catalyst to
address cultural and societal challenges
or to or to tackle difficult Topics by
the presentation of new possibilities
challenges preconceptions and tickles
our imagination let's welcome Hans to
share more Hans
please hello everyone I'm Hans uh thank
you for for coming I feel really
privileged to be able to speak to you
today uh it was not until Don's
introduction that I feel a little bit
left out I thought was just among
friends and uh and uh and uh but I'll do
my best with this small project that I
did three years
ago Alpha repair is a project that I
started in about
2020 uh and uh it was a project very
very close to my heart because I've
always thought that the you know we are
all familiar with the three hours of
sustainability we learn in primary
school and I've always felt that repair
is like the Forgotten sister or the
small brother of the Tre hours and uh
you know for me uh tackling the idea of
repair is really interesting if we use
creativity to do that instead of just
repairing something for the sake of
restoration so in 2020 I initiated this
project and co-presented exhibition and
a book together with design Singapore at
a national Design Center in early
20121 uh as a curator piece this project
really investigates the rule of repair
through design and communicates it to
the audience through the exhibition and
the book and I'll just really like to
acknowledge the team that's been working
on this there are many many designers
that involved the call team you know
involv uh Justin who was working on the
text the beautiful photographs and
documentation was done by C and and GID
and Jamie worked on the graphic design
for the exhibition and also for the book
design uh just to put this really up
front uh sustainability is really a big
issue issue and I always believe that
you know issues pertaining to the
broader levels of sustainability is
really really complex and we really
require large scale systemic Solutions
and even policies that involves many
many stakeholders that are needed to
really shift the tide uh for example the
right for repair movement is getting
ground in the EU something that you
might be aware of and uh the British
government introduced the right to
repair law uh that went into effect
actually in 1 of July 2021 when we
launched exhibition uh and and this is
really to increase producer
responsibility in making their products
easier to repair at the same time you
might be familiar with this as well if
you use Apple product in in November in
the same year 2021 Apple introduced and
announced the self-service repair scheme
that allowed more repairers to
legitimately Repair Apple
products at the same time while this is
all good I think R for repair plays a
very special role and plays a part in
this conversation of repair by doing two
things number one we really wanted to
explore repair at a very conceptual
level and number two we wanted to speak
to our relationship with repair at a
very personal
level so this informs the underpinnings
of the curatorial uh point of view and
for me I've always believed that to
really look at repair we really need to
transfer our perception of repair as a
restorative act to a transformative
act and we really want through this
project to reimagine the role of repair
as an inspiring activity that could lead
and produce aspiring outcomes through
design so the curatorial program
involved two main parts I'll just talk
about the repat projects the repat
objects first before moving to the
repits uh an open call was done over
about 3 to four days as far as I can
remember through social media and we
invited the public to volunteer broken
faulty objects anyone could submit
objects as long as you wrote a small
story about it about why you want object
repair and uh you know we had a range of
objects like a very very old IE eye po
if I'm not wrong we have clay pots uh
glasses uh a big Singer sewing machine
that was all broken down and uh and the
wood was rotting uh and in the
submission form you know we also allowed
the owners to write stories about the
objects that they were volunteering for
repair at the same time I shortlisted
about 10 uh designers from Singapore who
are based in Singapore and I pack them
with 10 objects that we sh listed uh and
uh this was really based on their design
eth thoughts and their expertise uh I
wanted to create a tension between the
objects and the designers so that
interesting not could come out of this
collaboration between the object and the
designers and also the owners these
designers came from a wide range of uh
disciplines uh they were from anything
from industrial Design Graphic Design uh
interaction Design jewelry design we had
a toy designer as well and and an
advertising agency so they were all
given full creative freedom with the
permission of the the object owners to
recreate these objects and to repair
these objects creatively uh one of the
really important elements that we did
was to facilitate conversations between
the designers working on the objects and
the objects owners so this was a really
interesting move for us because during
these conversations the designers could
learn a lot more about each of the
stories uh and memories behind each of
these objects that were broken or torn
and uh and these deeper insights gave
the designers a lot of am ation and
meaning to work with so they were
essentially not just repairing the
objects per se as tangible things they
were also transforming the stories that
came with it and it was really evident
in the repair outcomes that the
designers interpreted these narratives
in each of this repair concept and I
like to share some with
you uh this is a Calin Klein Tob that
was volunteered by Arnold go and he
bought this with his very first paycheck
when he graduated from University it
followed him through many jobs and after
many years of use it developed a lot of
holes uh and it was very Tor and it was
relegated into a grocery bag so what
Tiffany uh the commission design for
design repairer for this object did was
really smart because she found that
surprisingly the inside of the back was
really well maintained so what she did
was she flipped the back inside out and
the outside became the inside and inside
became the outside so all the holes now
were inside and you could not see it
anymore and the inner lining became the
of the back which looked kind of really
good uh and you could use it um maybe
for Double D span but what she did uh
was also uh to add a mesh cord as you
can see on the right to strengthen the
back and also to expand its capacity but
at the same time if you already Realize
by now uh it drew connections to the uus
mesh grocery bags that we might be quite
familiar
with uh next we had a pair of really
faded moving tickets volunteer by a very
young cute couple uh it it was from
their first date I'm not sure you can
make up from the tickets on the right
they really faded right it was for The
Amazing
Spider-Man so the the movie was a really
big deal for this couple because their
first date and they all they're both uh
introverts uh so they kept an album of
all their dates and this was the very
first
one and uh what Jonathan Yen the
commission designed for this project uh
did was uh he thought that you know uh
he didn't want to reinstate the peace
per se or the the tiets was really uh
faded but he thought that it was really
important to preserve The Faded tickets
as evidence of the beauty of time
passing in their relationship so uh what
he did was he designed and uh made a a
thoughtfully created augmented reality
filter where the owners using their
phones could use a app and they able to
hover over the tickets and to see it in
its mint restor condition but when they
don't use the app it still appears
really really
faded uh so when you know I would
imagine that when they see for the when
they see the tickets restored you know
it was as if they were holding the
tickets for the first time when they had
the first
date it was really interesting also and
I've not reviewed this in any
presentations that uh when we Pat the
designer to the object we found out that
one of the object owners uh the guy uh
was actually a student in graphic design
and one of his Heroes was Jonathan
y uh next up we had uh a a ankle
bracelet which was uh volunteered by Yen
Lee as you know in most Asian and
Chinese families when you like a baby uh
your parents will tie a gold bracelet
around your uh one of your feet that's
quite a common thing to do uh uh in many
cultures that's Asian as well and uh and
Yen kept this bracelet with her for many
many years because she treasured uh it
been given to by her father and her
mother and it broke when she grew out of
it uh so what this this piece of work
was reped was uh they were repaired by
State Property I think they happened to
have a shop near by near praka Museum
actually and what they did was really
meaningful uh because they took the the
the teddy bear that was broken and cast
it into a gold piece and inserted a
diamond Into the Heart of the bear to
symbolize how precious this piece of
jewelry is to the owner and at the same
time when you connect all the new restor
BS together it fit the wrist size of the
owner and she could use it all over
again uh this was a pair of spectacles
as you can see on the right uh donated
by m Jong she just relocated to
Singapore she's from Korea and the pair
of spectacles that she really love was
destroyed by her young daughter and she
tried to repair very unsuccessfully
using the orange paste as you can see
you might be able to see here clearer so
uh this was kinetics interpretation of
the repair and uh instead of working on
the glasses uh halfway through the
project they asked me for 3D scans of
the owner say I was like oh what in the
world are you doing and what they did
was really interesting because uh uh
with the 3D scans of the owner H they
TRD printed and built the H and the
Torso of the owner and adjusted her head
to fit the Wayward spectacles instead so
she they didn't repair the spectacles
they repair the owner's
head I thought that this piece of work
although it's quite uh conceptual and
pushes the boundaries but it really
captured the spirit of the whole art for
repair project because it really
challenged our ideas of repair and
sometimes perhaps it's not the repairs
that require it's not the objects that
require repair perhaps it's our
perception our perspective that requires
a little bit of repairing as well so
this project culminated in about 10 uh
repair products and I don't have time to
go through all of them as much as I wish
to uh but I'll just like to talk a
little bit of the repair kits as well
that made up the exhibition so these
repair kits were uh done in the design
studio i l at the National University of
Singapore these students were from the
Department of industrial design and the
brief to them was to design a process of
repair not a repair object or to repair
an object but design a unique process of
repair a novel technique of repair that
goes beyond reinstating the utility of
an everyday object so the outcome must
be better off than the previous uh uh
object where it's broken and the
technique must be contained in the rest
small kit and be mass
producible and with simple instructions
any Layman should be able to use it uh
the students came up with really
interesting uh and fascinating outcome
uh one of the groups was uh a group that
came up with a kit uh that you're able
to seal the holes and tests on the shoe
by painting over them they discovered
that you could paint with uh a special
rubber that cured in room temperature
and just by provide providing masking
stickers or you could do it freehand
yourself you could paint over TS and
holes and the lasts of pretty
long uh there was also a kit where you
can personalize a very small piece of
decorative work that will cover those
ugly exposed War plug you know on the
wall that sometimes you know you didn't
care to plaster
over and also uh this group of students
manipulated a soldering iron and make
customiz tips so that you could repair
plastic products made of thermoplastics
yeah through plastic welding and with
the different types of tips you could
actually choose the patterns that you
want to engrave or well the Plastics
with so with these repair kits uh uh in
this exhibition that we made it was made
during uh the pandemic season so covid
was running high and uh the funny thing
was although all the workshops were all
closed down and we couldn't run any
workshops which we initially thought we
wanted to uh we discovered that we could
actually post these kits uh just by post
to participants so we conducted four
fully subscribed Workshop over two
weekends and the students running this
workshop and instructing and teaching
the participants how to repair the
objects at home when they receive these
kits so these two the repair kits
together with the repair objects came
together as the content of the
exhibition and in a spirit of alpha
repair we did the exhibition design as
well we wanted to design exhibitions
very responsibly because it's quite
common for exhibitions to generate a lot
a lot of waste so other than the vinyls
on the wall that you see uh no adhesive
no pains uh zero onsite construction was
done for the exhibition setup all the
graphic elements the text elements all
help done with magnets on on the pieces
of uh display furniture and each
exhibition display module was
deliberately designed for an afterlife
as a site table composing of fiber drum
produced by a company in Singapore and
gavine steel surface held down by its
own
weight so we had a adopt a table public
call towards the end of the exhibition
within 7 hours all 70 tables were fully
booked uh so effectively on the last day
of the exhibition right all all the
table adopters came to the exhibition
and collected their their tables and
they essentially became our tear down
team so we spent $ Zer on te down they
some of them even bought some of the AC
all acryic cases they we used to cover
the
works and in 2022 I was very very th
that the success of this project led to
a second edition of arha repair it was a
collaboration between London and
Singapore and I co-created this
exhibition with a very prominent uh
curator called Jane Withers in the UK so
using the same format we had objects
this time from both Singapore and also
in uh the UK and we have designers
commission from both Singapore in the
UK as you can see on the top you have
the Puffin with the very broken wing uh
it was broken by the owner cat and what
seeing the designer who repaired this
object was to really cover the broken
wing with we woven returnan and in fact
if you can see the Puffin also has a new
belt and a small back with a small
message that tells the owner to take
care of of it
better we had a very special object as
well uh two special ones we had a 18th
century uh uh Victorian cabinet as you
can see on the top uh but on the top
right uh we have a plate from maxims De
Paris uh this plate was actually donated
or volunteered by Andrew Burkin the
English screenwriter and uh with his
wife Karen Burkin uh Andrew Burkin is
the brother of Jane the late Jane bkin
actress and singer uh which the bkin
back is named after after so she stole
this plate she pinched this plate as we
call it politely in English uh from uh
the the restaurant that she always
frequents and passed it on to the
brother and it was one of the plates
were broken uh in his possession and he
volunteered this plate to be repaired by
a studio
Dam you know I I hope to have have the
time to run through all these really
really fascinating repair projects uh
the the the projects were all in this
case in the second exhibition H at the
Victorian Albert Museum museum in London
and it ended last November in 2022 so uh
not only did this project bring the
message to a wider audience it was done
at the world's leading Museum of Art and
Design it became a platform also to show
local design Talent so if you want to
learn more about these different
projects the background of this projects
and how these projects were repaired do
visit the arha repair website thank
[Applause]
you
thank you Hans for that wonderful
sharing we will now invite our last
speaker for today's Forum he is none
other than designer of the Year Mr
Leonard okpo Country Market director for
Hing lasson in ape lennard's academic
background and design interest lies at
the juncture between Mankind and its
environment with the aim of finding a
long-term sustainable balance between
them his approach involves extensive
collaboration with diverse professions
to ferment holistic landscape based
solutions that engage and educate users
while while respecting the environment
his recent Works include design that
integrates the water found on site with
the surrounding Urban Development in a
sensitive manner recent project Awards
include the International Federation of
landscape architecture Asia Pacific
award for outstanding award in parks in
open space for the Jong Lake Gardens
2021 the president's design award design
of the year for kampong admiralty 2020
and the International Federation of
landscape AR architecture aapme award
for outstanding a award for the suai buo
Wetland Reserve in 2018 without further
Ado let's put our hands together and
welcome design of the Year Leonard to
share about his
[Applause]
practice thank you for the
introduction uh uh before I start my
lecture proper I first like to
congratulate all my fellow winners all
right uh really inspired by your work uh
and and look for many more years of good
outcome from you secondly like to thank
uh my fellow collaborators and my team
members who are here in today some of
them are here today uh industry Partners
uh and fellow designers have
collaborated on many projects has been
very accepting of our design uh some of
our clients here who was prepared to
experiment with designs that have not
proven uh even though the outcome was
not certain right and finally my family
who's not here today uh without all of
you this journey would not have been
possible thank you very
much so I I'll start my lecture with
this uh who do you want to be this is a
question that a lot of us ask
ourself mostly at important inflection
points in our lives right where we we
are possibly where we not happy what
we're doing or we are searching for new
opportunity so I ask I ask myself this
several times in my life
one time was this in
1987 I'm not sure how many of you will
recognize this movie this probably you
know predates a lot of your your your
time but uh I was I just graduated from
University then it was 1987 I came back
with a newly minted uh Finance degree
and I saw this
movie and I wanted to be that guy
Charlie Shin unfortunately I don't share
his looks but I share his passion right
I share his
passion to be a big dealer in Wall
Street I didn't make it Wall Street but
I made it to be a Trader so I I worked
for 15 years in a bank right had a
proprietary training for bonds and
Futures uh and work in Singapore
actually work in London it was really
good 15 years right but I realized
towards the end of that career that you
know this was not a career you can
retire
with I needed to look for something more
sustainable right and I realized through
trying different things I realized I
wanted to do
something that could make a difference
to people's life I was in a I was in
this profession that benefited the banks
and the shareholders right my effort was
reflected in the plus and minus column
of The Ledger every year there was no
Goodwill I started from zero every other
year so so that got me thinking what do
I want to do for the rest of my life who
do I want to
be so this is a a really nice sentence
by Will Durant to give life a meaning
one must have a purpose Larger than Life
which is not to say that my previous
banking job was not
purposeful it played a role all right
you do it for your family you do it for
your friends you do it for your team you
do it for a country everybody have got
your reasons they're all valid right but
what what he is saying is if youve got
purpose be
yourself then it makes your your your
your your effort
Noble and there are many purpose out
there that requires attention
you see this on a daily basis in news I
mean you have seen this
today and this we experiencing this we
right in the midst of a heat wave all of
this requires attention effort and
passionate Personnel to pursue
this and know
increasingly as we confront you know
what Humanity has done to
environment
I I realized that I want to make a
difference and therefore I wanted to
become a landscape
architect soor I thought that's not
entirely true I I I need to be honest
with you actually I wanted to become an
architect I knew that what
happened but the truth is at a point in
time I was 38 years old I was well into
my first career I was looking to start
the second
career and it was a lot to give up one
day I was head of proprietary
trading in the bank right running a team
of
Traders the next day or the next week I
was an intern in
nart the runway to be an architect to be
a QP is much longer than architect so I
took the easy way out I became a l
architect but I must say after having
been in this business for a while now I
don't regret it I don't regret it
because of the people I've
met the things I've seen and the things
I've
done let's talk about being a landscape
architect okay landscape architecture
itself right had carries with it some
baggage some
misconceptions right for the longest
time my kids taught that I was just a
glorified
Gardener which is
actually true in the way landscape
actually practiced in many areas and how
Landscape Architects are regarded by
many fellow
disciplines
right so I I see myself as a Advocate
and activist for the profession to I
want to I want to change the perception
I want to change it because I feel that
there's a much bigger role we can play
right so I see myself as a champion for
nature how do you bring the best show
the best of nature to the design
interventions you do and you don't have
to do much you can do the little bit and
nature will takes care of
itself so we try to do that in every
single project you know for example
recycling tree locks as little Play
Elements little gestures like that makes
a difference to people how how people
experience the
space I see ourselves as ecosystem
thinkers we increasingly we cannot work
in
isolation very few disciplines right can
conduct The Business Without
contribution of other disciplines right
we are all interconnected and we need to
understand what our fellow designers are
doing in order to bring out the best in
yourself right for example how do we
integrate Water Systems in the buildings
and Landscape so that they conceive as
one
system and finally I see our as
storytellers I just had a
conversation out in the meeting room
just now and somebody was saying ah you
know we losing memories of the space
right our relationship States is
becoming more tenuous because what we
remember is
gone and we need to create new
narratives in our in in our physical
space we need to build opportunities for
memories so that it doesn't have to be
beautiful but it has to be a space where
you
remember for the right
reasons any space is an opportunity to
create
memories it's really up to your
imagination so now I'm going to run
through the
projects uh actually these four projects
I'm going to show you uh one the
president design award I wanted to show
you because it an IT demonstrates an
evolution of my design and how how I was
trying to embed My Philosophy
into uh into this uh design Solutions so
this was my very first project after I
graduated from
University uh and this is new Majestic
hotel right it was a really simple
intervention there the owner had this
little sver of land they actually didn't
belong to him in front of the hotel and
he was trying to convince the
authorities to give it to him to so that
he can do something for for the
community then he approached me he says
hey what can you do with this sver of
land the problem this SLI of land is was
really tiny it was like th000 Square ft
and then there were high tension cables
running underneath so I can't do
anything below it has all to be resting
on the ground so the idea was to create
this series of me uh ribbons that
Meander and form a
landscape so I devised this series of
pots that looks like if you put them
together look at a series of ribbons you
just place them on top top of the
ground and make it into a simple
landscape that looks like it's part of
the ground but actually
pots it's no longer there right uh and I
don't regret but when it was there it
was well used people were sitting on it
the kids running up and down the ribbons
right and it it it provided a beautiful
backdrop even though it's small little
pocket park it Prov backdrop for the
community
there the next project that was involed
involved in was part of the team for
bishan
Park so uh we were then called AAL dry
CLE and
uh pu was uning embarking on this
program called uh ABC
Waters right uh and ABC Waters was
really not about
beautifying
Rivers it really was about changing
mindsets and why were they Wan thing
change mindsets it had to do with uh our
need to protect water as a resource you
know Singapore has a limited that land
area we have to rely on imported water
right but that's not
sustainable so one of the programs are
to increase the catchment of water right
but water is only useful if it is clean
and doesn't require too much resources
or energy to make it usable so the whole
idea is look now that we have
demonstrated that uh it's possible to
clean Singapore River let's impound all
the rivers right collect all the water
and recycle them as drinking water and
they want to do it for all the
catchments and this is one of catchment
right so the idea is when it rains you
catch a se you clean it you beautify it
you use to activate the space and with
that beautiful space people will use it
they'll build memories and then they are
less likely to l and pollute they take
ownership of the
space so it went from this know the
canal being a separator of
community and where they
play we use nature based Solutions right
to replace the
concrete and this was the result right I
mean the uh the the the advantage of
having this as opposed to Canal I think
it's obvious right to Nature to man and
for your
well-being we used the native uh uh land
uh landscape material to create
beautiful
landscapes and we we also devis a
landscape uh strategy that allows uh
natural El evolution of of of plants
native plants so that they are not fixed
in a place they evolve over time
and really we want to create a space
that respects nature provides space for
nature to coexist
harmoniously so that we can build
memories for the
future right and with this we hope that
people will learn to treasure water as a
resource understand the value of design
so to me this was probably the most
satisfying part of the entire design so
this was doing after a storm event right
and there were members of public writing
in the Forum right explaining the
purpose of the design to other members
they felt were ignorant they says look
this is not flat this is planned right
and to me that validates that actually
now you have a buy in now you can step
back and let the public play its
role
the next project that we run uh PDA for
was Jong Eco
Garden and this was actually an
industrial park right uh but it was
non-existent it was actually it looks
like a verden forest really thick really
beautiful right and they wanted to
develop a plot at a time so we went in
there and proposed that maybe you should
create the green and blue infrastructure
first right so that then you use that as
an as an inducement for the developers
to come in
but when we went in there and
investigate and started digging in we
found that it had meters of garbage
under the green actually it was a
dumpsite for many many many
decades so one of the strategy was okay
you know let's with this green
refracture use water right as a strategy
to
remediate all these pollutants Lee them
out of the soil treat them before it's
discharged right into the public
space and a simple gesture of just
including water cses in a really athetic
manner having them treated right in uh
bio retention uh bio remediation bed
right and integrate very simless with
the
surroundings the last project that won
this as the compy which uh we work with
warart they are the lead architect on
this and we the Landscape Architects and
we wanted to create an elevated ground
ground plane right to bind communities
because you know when you live in Flats
the ground plane is very far from you
how do you create this new elevated
ground
plane and this project would not have
been POS possible without a close
collaboration with all the different
disciplines you cannot get a picture
like this right if you invite as an
architect if you invite a landc
architect after you have done your
building it is not possible because you
need to embed waterproofing you need to
embed irrigation you need to provide for
loading you need to do all those
things and we embedded Water Systems
from fully recycling systems for
irrigation this was the image uh during
construction you notice all the hard
roofs and the senior citizens who living
in the tower blocks will be looking at
this one year later this is what they
got
a beautiful landscape
Hillside and you know it makes an entire
difference to your your
life this is a new project that open a
couple of years ago jurong ecosystem we
wanted to recreate lowland freshwater
swarm that used to be found there in
jurong right but it was really now we
went beyond creating spaces for humans
we wanted to also provide for nature
stakeholders right we looked at what was
there the gr herand and we provided
spaces for them we created islands for
them to make them feel secure and we
also provide feeding zones by creating
these M Flats but we allow people to to
uh interact with them but from a
distance right so people cannot get down
to where they feeding but can view from
afar so
this was a rendering without during
competition stage and this was a video
we to uh we took just before
opening and that image of the bird
flying in the sky that was the image we
wanted to
create
so now it's a space that uh you know is
really wellc coming and I I I I was told
that uh it was it was really a welcome
relief during the covid-19 right it was
it was actually not view as a luxury it
was view as necessity right and and this
is really where the storytelling comes
in you know where you do memories right
where people come back to again and
again and this is actually we pull this
out from Instagram it's actually not
Japan this is Singapore this is J Lake
Gardens so I end by saying what next
right uh there's still a lot more to do
there's still a lot more potential to
this uh um profession and the
collaboration with our fellow uh uh
design professionals so this project
right now we're deing doing for uh
Singapore food agency which is a liukang
master food master plan uh food
resilience is becoming a really hot
topic how do we combine food resit
production with coastal defense with
climate change with
biodiversity right with uh uh limited
Water Resources these are topics that
need to be explored right we explor we
are also exploring new ways to play you
know now the kids have got you know
options yeah they've got virtual options
my kids are constantly on the on
PlayStations how do we enti them them uh
into the physical
world climate change heat island effect
you know exploring how do we improve our
thermal Comfort is another big
topic and finally the health of our
oceans and our seas
right so this I I think is really
important not just me but for everyone
else in this room to ask your yourself
this question how can you make a
difference
thank
[Applause]
you thank you Leonard for that very
inspiring
presentation actually Leonard could you
please take a seat in the front yeah
yeah I hope everyone found the sharing
by all the speakers insightful we will
now move on to the Q&A segment I invite
the rest of the panel members to please
join Leonard at the at the seats in the
front
okay moderating the session is Miss Wong
rening ring is a designer specializing
in interiors and Landscape architecture
she works as a project designer at Rios
an international design Collective with
a transdisciplinary approach she
combines her education in architecture
and Landscape AR architecture with
professional experience in interior
design to drive Innovation and create
Unique Designs alongside her role at
Rios she teaches part-time at the
department of architecture National
University of Singapore inspire iring
and mentoring aspiring designers while
bridging Academia and practice Runing
contribute continues to contribute to
the design Community through her active
involvement in organizations like the
Singapore Institute of Landscape
Architects and the landscape industry
Association Singapore ladies and
gentlemen the panel is ready please take
this opportunity to ask any questions
you might have you may scan the QR code
shown on the screen to submit your
questions and we will also take
questions from the floor if if there are
any I'll now hand over the mike to
rening to begin the segment
right so uh as you guys are slowly
typing furiously your questions into the
thing I think I will start off with the
first question so um I think hongway and
Hans did something what I loved is they
showed their slide and they showed the
number of people who are involved in the
different projects and that it takes uh
it's not just a sort of a solo designer
who runs these amazing things you see
but it's a multi-disciplinary team so I
guess this is a question that I'll ask
all four of them but maybe we start with
Hong way um how um how is a
multidisciplinary approach valuable when
designing with sustainability in
mind yeah
yeah yeah I think um coming specifically
from uh the Singapore Pavilion
perspective um what we did was we were
actually War to heads We Are The
Architects as well as the creative
director um and and it's a unique
project because it goes beyond uh
architecture itself and I think we also
have to work similarly with the entire
team to bring the Pavilion together and
up and uh I think learning through and
getting to know um different creative
minds right from operations from
management from FNB
retail uh to
engineering um it's it's important to be
able to collaborate and to work together
as a team because the sum is definitely
more than the parts right so I think it
has been a very meaningful and
productive Journey uh it's it took
longer uh than what we expected um but I
think the outcome is something that we
are all very proud of um in fact I think
we were we had many sleepless nights
especially the in the months uh leading
towards the opening because now we
really want to make this uh good product
uh from
Singapore thank you for that um Hans you
want to try and take a stab at how maybe
you Embrace multi-is approach in your
day-to-day
practice there you go this works right
okay uh maybe I start answering question
in the context of the project alha
repair uh to be honest Al for repair was
quite straightforward although I was
working with uh 10 designers from
different fields of design uh also with
a team that was in charge of putting the
exhibition together uh it was it wasn't
difficult because uh the design industry
is in Singapore is quite small I knew
all the designers personally uh so they
didn't have much choice but to deliver
what they promised uh uh but besides the
point is uh we did a project at the
height of covid so one of the reasons
why I thought it was really interesting
to launch the project was because it was
a time where all the projects were
starting to be cancelled and we wanted
to breath life into that season to brief
creativity in the season where projects
are starting to diminish yeah and to
launch it where the covid was starting
to alleviate and to bring visitors back
to the National Design Center so this
was one of the first exhibition uh at
the design center after the uh after
people were allowed to visit exhibitions
so for me that is really important uh
apart from this project in my personal
Design Studio I do work alone so I am
that loan designer that you just
described sorry no problem so so I
worked on a very individual basis uh but
uh the way I work as a curator is to
bring different elements uh together not
as a company working together but you
know as collaborators working together
so every project I work with I work with
a set of different uh collaborators
depending on the need and the nature of
the project thank you for that n did you
want to add sure uh I I think it's
critical for that projects we do it is
so complex that uh not uh no single
person has all the required knowledge
for example you know um take out bishan
Park you need a hydraulic engineer right
you need Landscape Architects you need
ecologist uh you need uh Architects you
need everybody in order to tap on the
different skill set right so that the
outcome is integrated right and is
multifunctional in its approach so uh if
you
seek uh a holistic uh uh approach that
really solves problems at multiple
levels then you really need to go
multifunctional and uh
integrated you
talk yeah I I think um to work as a
collaborators is also important for us
to understand what other profession uh U
backgrounds right we we it's not just
that we learn and strengthen our own
skill but also to learn from other
profession practice right for if I'm a
landsc architect I have to know what is
the mind of Architects what is the
engineers behaviors and then we can
communicate
better okay no that's great um so I had
a a question just so that Anton since
you here with the mic um so you spoke
about reinvention right turning
adversity into opportunity setbacks into
comebacks and I wanted to reflect on
this but also to also relate this to how
you mentioned that you were working on a
super compressed timeline which I think
for many of us who are in the industry
we are completely familiar with this
sort of constraint so I want to know how
did you transform that constraint that
in a way it's a setback to work with
such a tight timeline into an
opportunity well yeah uh when when we
get the projects we were tasked by the
by the uh governments
finish it in one year 12 months design I
thought it's just design but it said
construction not design said it's
impossible we never done this in
Singapore right one months to finish a
project uh even they don't have a
topography plan so it was super
challenging and I asked myself whether
it's possible but in the end we don't
want to miss the opportunity we took the
job and as we started I think it's the
power of and it was during the C time I
couldn't travel to Jakarta everyone was
working remotely right um it was the
power of visionary leaders of course
from the stakeholders they think they
can then they have to pull everyone so
everyone had to be in the same basket by
bringing people together everyone have
to support each other decision has to be
made faster so from the design from the
Consultants from the stakeholders that
to say yes but of course you have to you
need to have a good design so I was
thinking
if a project can be done in short time
is the is benefit for everyone from
stakeholders you save a lot of time and
the most benefit is the users right the
community they can see the changes maybe
we prepare this President design award
for 12 months right but that 12 months
can be transformed into new parks that
has been uh attracting so many millions
of people has come to the park and I
think it's really about the drive from
the team members and working with a
constraint it bring out your uh
creativity and the adrenaline to succeed
uh in everything that you
do thank you thank you for that um do
any of you guys want to comment or add
to that share similar anecdotes are
working in super compressed
timelines okay no um so then I will pick
up on the last point that you that you
also made but I think also let it made
it's about the the importance of the
user recognition and designing um for
people I think you mentioned social
inclusivity um and so I guess this is a
question for all four of you um is how
do you actively seek to learn from users
in your practice um or and maybe to add
to that um maybe you can speak of an
instance where your views or your
process as a designer has changed as a
result of Engagement um with user either
through feedback or or even if it's
through those facilitated conversations
um that came purposefully in the process
so maybe Hong way you been quiet I'll
start with
you right um how do we engage and how
how do we learn right um not not
specific to the Singapore Pavilion but I
think as a practice uh we do want to
know how our buildings how design
performs and and definitely when you
measure something you can improve on
that right so I think um we are always
interested in how our building performs
and how the building can be productive
and regenerated productive in the sense
that how it enables uh people to be
happy or how it enables our ecosystem
services so these are all measurable and
I think once you measure them and by
taking in feedback by looking at social
media on what are the comments are
what's valuable to the people uh to the
stakeholders to the occupants and I
think then you you take it through uh
and see what else you can do for the
next
project um I think as designers most of
you will probably agree that you know it
never ends right you're always designing
trying to improve it to the very last
moment but even after you send in
attended documents you still think about
how you can improve it right even after
you build it you still thinking about
how you improve it so every step of the
way having feedback is really important
uh because if it doesn't fit into this
particular project it fits in the future
project uh and and that's how we see our
practice right we constantly striving to
improve um and feedback is
critical uh and For Me Maybe in design
especially in product industrial design
we often ass share being user centered
that's a very important thing and I
really agree with that uh more often
than not we associate user Center design
with use uh with performance uh and also
uh with utility at the same time and and
I also learned a lot from lennard's
presentation today that stories and
meanings are also part of people's use
and it defines who we are and our
experiences with things so these are
things that we can also look into and
that is something that we tried to
tackle in the AL for project uh one
could have easily given objects to
designers
to create them uh to interpret them
creatively in terms of how they want to
repair but the story component related
to this object was really the Pinnacle
of what we were wanting to transform
instead and I think that worked out to
some extent quite successfully uh with
the designers really incorporating them
into the interpretations at the
end further to that
um from um the Singapore pillon
experience I think what what was
important to to us is that if I canor
saying is that people will forget uh
what you tell them people forget what
you show them but people will not forget
how you make them feel right so I think
that was something that we wanted to do
to really uh take a step back create a
different environment uh create a
respect from the rest of the Expo ground
and to make them feel that they enjoy
the space they get connected with nature
and I think throughout the process uh
even post uh Expo we have been getting
good feedbacks from Medias and and there
were a lot of coverage uh on on the
pavillon on online and and that was
something that was uh we take away from
in terms of what we try to do how we
represent Singapore and uh it also
pushes us to see what else we can do
further in know future
projects yeah I think involvement of
users is very important for some in Eco
Park before we build a Parks uh the
government arrange the focus group
discussion involve everyone stay around
the TS from the governments to the local
residents to give the feedback what do
they want for the parks and that is
listed in um written documents some said
I was I want a fish pawn I want a beauty
River I don't want the garbage right and
with all those decision we we table it
and we use as a reference for our design
no point if we design something like in
Singapore but it's not adapt it's not
useful in in Jakarta so we have to know
what is the context and other than T
eopa I think uh there's a two things
that we need to negotiate the art of
negotiation is important also in our job
right uh um stakeholders have a budget
right user have this demand so is as
designer is really about how to bridge
these two needs especially if you work
on the private sector project it's much
more difficult yeah if you want to serve
a community with certain budgets so we
need to find that uh Middle Ground uh as
designers to accommodate all the users n
I'll like to add by you know I think
user play the important role of keeping
designers real right sometimes designers
think oh I got it all figured out I know
exactly how they're going to use this
all right and then I design the
playground and I go to the playground
and I see the kids hanging off the rails
as oh I never imagin that will
happen right and and at the end of the
day is how they use it uh through their
own experience how they view your your
design to the lens of their uh uh their
needs that's the one that's going to
make a real impact on them and and and
we all should be open to the idea that
you know uh that uh what we have
intended may not be how they use it we
must be prepared to
change well Leonard since you have the
mic there there are I think two two
questions that uh have come in that I
think are interrelated and that they're
um they're directed to you so I think
they're the two questions are related in
the sense the question asked um how and
where did you find the courage to move
away from your 15 years wellestablished
banking career to start completely fresh
maybe there are people contemplating the
same thing right now um and and in the
same vein as as when you when you did
that pivot how did you um
so quickly rise to the top so to say to
lead um the
studio I get asked that a lot and I need
to correct that
misconception first off there was no
courage there was a lot of fear right
and there was a lot uncertainty right
and the transition wasn't fast it was
slow it took a long time to climb up so
but you know you come to a a point in
life where as I said you know you you
you at that point in my life at least I
was begin to question what am I doing
right there was you know if you have
problems waking up in the morning going
to work then you need to ask yourself
that
question what will get you out of bed
right and and I think I was at that
point I I was seeing friends in the
training department burn out right
really down and and I I didn't want that
to happen to myself I I didn't want to
be told that I'm going to be laid off
right I want to leave on my own terms
right but I I realize that because of
the changing economy and new economy
right it's very difficult to have a
career that last your entire life time
right so inevitably for most of you
there will be a change right and and and
it it's going to be a difficult question
and it depends on personal experience
right it's easier if you got no
obligations it's a lot more difficult if
you got obligations right but
nonetheless you know you need to come to
your own terms you need to be real and
you need to be honest with
yourself well
done um so now I think there are some
questions that are quite specific to the
project and I guess we we can go through
them so I think we starting with the
with the Singapore uh Pavilion um we
always like to know they want to know
what are the key challenges faced
uh how did the team you know how long
did it team take to conceptualize the
design to construct it uh how long that
did that take and then the cost if that
is possible to
share the cost um how long the it it was
a design competition uh that we got us
uh involved in uh in this uh
project um it took longer than expected
because of covid there was a big uh
curveball that was thrown
along the way um up Upstream I think um
the design took less than a year I mean
we are clear in what we wanted uh we the
simple idea was to create an oasis in
the desert that was what we put in in
our submission but we know it's uh never
simple to be simple right um You have to
hold on to that singular idea and and
make sure everybody fall in line in
terms of the delivery uh where the touch
points are
or when we tell the story so so that was
something that uh we uh along the way
had to hold a forth and uh make sure
that it's uh delivered uh as per what we
have promised uh in the submission uh
it's also Oasis for the census uh in in
the sense that we wanted
to uh create a space that offers respect
from the information overload from the
Expo I'm not sure anyone have been there
but know going through 90 country
pavillons I'm sure you know you get
tired out so um what we did was to
really offer a space of garden where the
guest are intuitively drawn into uh to
escape from um the hustle and bule right
so that was something that uh we um
rigorously tried to make sure that
happened cost cost no I can't review
that I tried I
tried um so for for Anon regarding the
park I think the there's a question also
on the more sort of understanding the
nitty-gritty um what were the authority
submissions uh required iner maybe I
guess in comparison to here uh and the
timelines required to get the approvals
before
construction oh yeah bring bring back to
a really rare memories uh there's no
beam submission yet in Jak and
everything is done manual right so we
have to bring the papers hard copies go
there and they they they they they do a
marking directly maybe just like in
Singapore maybe 20 years ago yeah we we
do a manual submission so it was done
and and we have a four
stakeholders involved right just like
the LTA pu and PX equivalent in jarta so
we have to go through one by one so it's
almost like weekly submission because
they want it to be cons red fast but we
also need a approval record right so
everything has to be done separately we
have a three or four teams engaged four
different stakeholders so it was a rush
project but they also because it's a
government project they also understand
the graphity that this is manded from
the governor so they have they pay
attention fully so to to get it done and
approved
also thank you thank you for that uh so
Hans uh there is a question here for you
uh in terms of the r for repair um how
did the collaboration with VNA happened
uh was it was it did that happen
organically was it planned from the from
the beginning so um and has the sort of
the message of the exhibition game on
Traction in Singapore after it went
overseas to
London uh when we did the first addition
in Singapore uh we did it at the
national Design Center uh what we were
really surprised is the amount of uh
attention it got especially in overseas
media and also in the local media and it
was really well recognized by a lot of
design magazines blogs and books that
were publishing articles about the
exhibition I think that was one of the
Catalyst of thinking about uh doing the
second edition uh I have to give credit
to design Singapore who really was was
really Visionary in think in thinking
about collaborating for second edition
and bringing the concept
uh to the wider audience uh so we were
looking for countries different
countries to collaborate with uh I could
say this now uh I didn't really want to
do it actually because there was so much
work uh so I gave them a very very
difficult task okay if you if we do it
if VNA wants to do it I'll do
it I remember it was VNA and the design
Museum in the UK very specifically if we
managed to get them on board I'll do it
unfortunately uh it was a seren bit
after City people knew each other and
somehow we got word and we got to know
the curators uh and of some of the
Galleries at the Museum and uh when we
presented the concept to them together
with design Singapore they told us yes
and they told us that it was the first
time they said yes in the meeting that
they saw a concept for the first time uh
so for us that that was that was that
really Vindicated all efforts that we
put in finding yeah a partner to do the
second addition and also how the first
addition was really impacting the people
who saw
it um so as please send in more
questions um as we are that's developing
I actually had a question uh for you
Hans in regards to your um so for off
for repair I like what you said it was
it's the sort of the Forgotten sister of
the three Rs reduce recycle um reuse
that whole Mantra was
sustainability um and in a way repair
you you could see it's part of that
antidote to the obsolescence that is
generally generated by consumerism so
just just something to PO not to put you
on this on the spot but had you ever
considered how you would if you had the
opportunity to extend that same
aspiration but on a different scale so
that if it wasn't a product material
physical scale um no budgets no no time
constraints where where would you where
would you see that idea also going if
you had a chance I'm a designer so I
wouldn't do any project as no
constraints if there's no constraints
you don't need a designer to do a
project yeah so I think that's one thing
uh so I can't I can't answer that
question based on that that constraint
of not having a constraint yeah yeah uh
but bringing this project to a wider
skill I think we for us in this project
when I first uh uh thought about it uh
the
curatorial uh the curatorial intent here
is really to shave the mindsets of the
imagination of a person who visits the
exhibition so for us dealing with
perceptions what you know before how you
see the stories and how you transform
your perception based on how you
transform the stories in your mind that
was really the underlying intent of a
citoral point of view in an exhibition
uh the pieces were just Vehicles the the
design were just vehicles to make that
happen so for us uh it's something that
we unfortunately we cannot measure it's
very difficult but from how we saw the
project took off in terms of publicity
uh and how people were really interested
in telling the story for us I think that
was that achieved a good level of
success yeah I think so then I think
this sort of quickly seg ways to a
question that uh audience member had
asked which was were there any further
spin-off interests and efforts in ARA
repair following both both uh Singapore
and London uh exhibitions Al for repair
three uh I'm not sure yet
[Laughter]
yeah uh yeah I will first start by
saying no first and let's see how it
goes all right gotcha gotcha so um I
will now I think turn to to hongway I
think there is a question here for you
that first says Hey kudos for a great
job representing Singapore um and the
question is uh I think it's quite open
I'll see how you want to go about it but
if the ultimate feedback validating your
work is how people
feel does measuring only the
quantifiable make better
[Laughter]
intangibles
yeah yeah to be fair everyone else can
answer this
too I think it's a base we that's what
the Hans was saying I think we need to
work with a brief we need to work with
constraint and I think that that that
pushes us to design something that uh
it's different we need to we need to
understand what are the constraints in
order to respond to it to act to it uh
so I think that that is a base uh that's
something that we have to do um but in
terms of the intangible I think that's
something that yes uh it's difficult to
measure uh and it's some it's difficult
to quantify and to react against um but
as I mentioned earlier I mean it's
something that
we try to make our our space meaningful
and purposeful and I think as what
Lenard also has shared uh if people in
the public can get it and respond on
behalf of the designer uh as uh seen
from the case of bishan par I think that
was that's a very powerful respon that
now the design can elicit from um the
public in in in the
outcome okay I'm going to take a shot at
this but you know this this is really
difficult for me but I'll try uh so from
what I understand okay um the quantifi
are normally uh based on uh uh perform
performance ative parameters right and
that's that's easy to measure right and
uh I believe with the Advent of AI
especially uh you they they're going to
increasingly do that part of the
business all right so I'm it's the
intentional part that I think we can
play a future role because these are the
part that difficult chaptured the
feelings the experience the memories and
I think that's
difficult uh to subcontract out to the
AIS uh and I think that's where we can
remain relevant for the future right uh
so I I don't think they're connected
actually uh not not not not so closely
one may provide information but they are
not directly connected and and and and
they both requires different skill set
that will be my
take
uh well for me an exhibition is quite
easy because especially this case uh uh
for both exhibitions uh the second one
we had in in London we had opening party
at a space in Singapore we couldn't have
opening party uh because it was during
covid although the museum just open but
I just happened to send everyone to ask
everyone to come back on the same date
so everyone happened to appear at the
same time as well uh and uh in that
session it was the first time the owners
saw their repairs being un they they
never saw in the process of how their
objects were being creatively repaired
and in those sessions both in London and
Singapore you know we had a lot of Tears
In Those sessions people seeing the
objects transform in the first time and
it was very moving uh so for me uh it
was really that moment in especially in
the Singapore Edition that I thought was
really a powerful tool that design has
always been uh designed to do is really
to move
people and to create these experiences
that we can all remember
maybe you should share with us some of
the videos they'll be
interesting okay um we have just I think
another question I think this quite
interesting one again for hung way
regarding the sing P Pavilion um and
it's quite in theme with the discussion
today so the question is since this is a
temporary structure with a
sustainability Focus were there any
considerations for the use of the
materials the planting
uh when the Expo ends definitely
um I mean it's uh it's a given it's a
six months exhibition period um and all
the country per villain have to go I
think on a bigger scale overall um the
Expo ground is planned as part of uh
Dubai Urban master plan 2040 so key
structures are are being retained so we
have the three key Pavilion uh in the
Expo ground that that was retained as
museums Galleries and institutions that
continue to serve uh the occupants in
the area so I think there's a legacy
plans there uh it's something good that
came out from the Expo there definitely
are alternative views that you know Expo
is uh not a really sustainable event but
see from a perspective that you know
it's a Once in five years event where uh
people come together to exchange ideas
and Innovations
and I think this is especially important
now where we have a very diversive world
and uh and the planet is getting sicker
right so I think that that's uh
something that I think it's important to
understand from high level uh view of
the Expo for for the Pavilion of course
I think we tried to make sure um we go
light it being a steel structure means
that it can be erected quickly and uh
deconstructed quickly
um we also kept the pallet as minimum as
possible so there wasn't too much
overlay in terms of material and I think
the plans was that um after the six
months event uh The Pavilion was handle
over to a local contractor that uh
Savage and repurpose and recycle
whatever that they can uh in in Dubai
there were actually initially some plans
to bring back one of the uh one if not
all three uh code uh to Singapore but we
couldn't do that because uh that will
incur carbon footprint on the way back
and that does not um fulfill the agenda
of uh
sustainability uh also I think from
coming off from covid um it also
um uh throw off some of the plans that
we had uh it was meant to be a uh event
that we could we wanted to connect
Singapore with with Dubai uh but because
of the circumstances there was too many
restrictions flying there was uh almost
impossible we actually wanted to bring
in Singapore amb ambassadors uh from the
local terer to go there to represent and
talk about Singapore and as well as
representative of the Singapore Brands
to be there to to show and tell about uh
the Singapore brand so that that
couldn't happen uh some parts of it
happened through uh video conferencing
which I think was something that uh also
came out from the covid
situation thank you for that so we have
a nice big question for each of you uh
and I think please do take each of you
take your time to sort of answer this so
the question is um what do you envision
for Singapore um what design what can
the design Community do contribute or
lead the way towards a better
future um um I may pick on Leonard to
start first because because I think it's
in vain with what you were saying about
making a difference um so if if you
don't mind
yeah well uh I I'll just repeat what I
said I think we all can make a
difference I think I think we we need to
step up and uh see how we can contribute
you know very little way even is a small
guesture right uh especially in design
design uh affects people uh and how they
lead their lives uh so even though you
you know you you're in office you're
doing stuff and you're wondering how
does this impact right uh and and that's
the question you have post to yourself
whatever you do all right uh am I doing
impactful
work if uh you're not then maybe you
should need to think about it right
right and try to make a change but I
understand that you know it is it is not
something you can do you know at every
point in time right it's a journey like
the journey that I took right I I didn't
make an impact for many years right you
need to build to that uh um position
where you can actually make real
difference right but if you are along
this journey I think then you're on the
right
path so maybe just to elaborate a little
bit back on this for you what is impact
or what is impactful in your
view um making a difference in people's
lives right uh improving how we um live
with nature right improving the
environment I could go all
day um okay um if I take a leave from
kin and Joshua's uh he care I think
heare is really to uh Better Care by
Innovations or improvisation so I think
that that's a spirit that we all have to
I mean regardless whether you're a
designer or not it's really a idea of
being caring and to be able to care
about your surroundings your your
environment your space right because um
being being careless is is wasteful
right if you being careful then I think
it's full positive uh I think that
attitude uh
would will resonate in whatever that uh
you you do whether or not it's design or
as as a user of the
space yeah I think um there's a shifting
of Paradigm in design we used to treat
design as a beautiful object
uh something that is Artistic and nice
and I think the PDA changed that mindset
in 2018 that it recognize the impact of
the design to be impactful whatever we
designed it has to look good but also
have a purpose right and driven by by
what we give to the community
environment and so on and I think
designer have a role solving the problem
that we have and there's a lot of
problem we have it can be from physical
environment it can be from digital
environment and that's the job of
designer if we work together who's doing
this uh collaboratively I think um and
through this WS also uh acknowledge that
recogn the recognition of what designer
have done I think that's we we can move
forward in AIT in in a for a better
better better future right so one thing
in E we we involve a lot of
collaborators right we don't just work
as a land arit we have architect we s
like the signage and the visual identity
we involve graphic designers to create
this um mcut for the for the parks
uh we also have a sculptor uh artist
that work on the SC sculpting the
dragonfly and and squirrel into the
parks so by doing that we also give
opportunity for many other field to be
involved in the project and I hope for
any type of project whether it's
architecture landscape or object it
should be a collaborative Works to
strengthen the profession of
designers uh I was trained classically
as industrial designer uh
in my bachelors and while while I was in
school we call ourselves Landfield
designers because industrial designers
are essentially product designers most
of what you see in land fields are
products and objects that last a long
long time your handphones electronic
circuits computers uh products uh these
are all most of these things have been
have gone through the hands of a
designer or but in specifically an
industrial designer so certainly uh
designers have a big big big role to
play in how we design a product but at
the same time I think we should not just
focus on the technical side of
sustainability I think we need to bridge
the meaning Gap if you think about
something that you have owned for the
longest of time unreasonably long uh
usually you hold on to it not because it
performs really well or because it uses
very well not because it looks really
good but you have a special meaning
attached to it and I think that's the
Gap we need to
bre okay well then I I think we can have
another question that I think is quite
interesting is also something I was
curious about and this is for each of
you um I think an audience member here
is interested to know what is next for
you guys projectwise so if you can I
mean uh if if you are if it's uh not
sort of reaching confidentiality
agreements um share a little bit of what
you're working on or what what other
projects you hope for your yourself to
do and be involved in in the next couple
of
years
maybe I can start by not really talking
about the projects themselves but
talking about philosophy so uh I believe
that we can do better than
sustainability uh sustainability
involves uh maintaining the status quo
right uh but you know we have brought a
lot of damage on the environment we need
to do better than that we need to
indulge in uh we need to actually
promote regenerative design design that
help to uh uh remediate and and and and
and heal
the environment and we all have a role
to play in
that yeah sustainability um I was just
explaining to my
boy I think few days ago um that I'm
coming for this forum um he came back
with a homework and asked me about what
is sustainability I was like you they
you they teach you in such words in
primary school
now um I I I reply him as it's uh the
ability to sustain right so I think it's
really very much how you can keep um you
have to you need to design for with the
ability to keep uh the thing going the
system going and um all the cycle going
so I'm not sure whether he understood me
or not but I think that's something that
I think all of us uh every every
designers planners innovators are doing
right it's really looking at uh asking
asking questions so I'd be curious about
it asking questions and uh make I think
manam was also telling us make a problem
as big as possible because that's where
the opportunity lies right once you're
able to solve a a problem you you can
solve many things because nowadays
everything are so everything is so
interconnected so I think that's that's
something that I think EO what is saying
that no we we need to look at uh our
projects or our surroundings our
environment uh with different lenses
different Optics and ask questions does
it really uh how does it help us uh be
sustainable um maybe just to add the
question about what's next right uh
interestingly uh we were asked back to
look at enabling Village uh that was a
project done about 10 years ago um um
back then there wasn't the the brief
wasn't quite and I think we we together
with the client went along it was also a
very quick project we turn over less
than um a year slightly more than a year
sorry um but I think as um over the
years uh uh it has attracted uh users
and occupants and I think they have
gotten more feedbacks on how to make uh
the village better and I think uh we so
it's it's also quite interesting that
know we get a second chance to go back
to repair to see what uh we can do more
to make the space to Value add to the
space and make it even better I think
that's something that I'm looking on I'm
looking forward to to
finish yeah
uh I think design is not one person
works it's a team collaboration you work
with the teams and and the next for me
is uh after we we receive this award is
really about uh inspiring my team to
to to our belief to our design
philosophy so they engage right uh and
ultimately if we have a good team then
we have a happy clients right so that's
the number one that we want to do for
internally to inspire our own teams
second uh the impact of this award
brought us uh many new inquiries right
for example there's one developers that
has been constructed a concrete Canal
halfway then they stop
it then they call me can you do
something like TB EOP Parks so we were
grateful because otherwise they we
create this long 1.3 kilomet of similar
Cana that we have deconstruct at turber
EOP Park and they want to build that
right so so that's what uh interesting
about if we have a successful projects
impactful projects of course e also
inspired by bishan Park and this goes
down to many other projects and now it's
to Jakarta so what's next is to continue
improving innovating and find new
solution and inspired many other people
to do a better
job yeah uh for me I don't do long-term
planning so I have no idea what I'm
going to do next month I just came off a
sabatical a onee sabatical uh that ended
in June uh I was supposed to cut a
vision for myself I realized that
there's no point doing it uh but I'm
just really excited to go back to
teaching uh for me teaching is like
designing the future your futur r
designing someone's else's mind who's
going to operate in the future and solve
complex problems in the future and for
me that is really a gratifying uh
position to be in and a very careful
position to be in as well uh and to that
my shortest term plan now is to be a
parent that my child needs me to
[Applause]
be and with that thank you very much for
your attention I think we will this is
the closing of the Q&A
thank you very much uh ladies and
gentlemen this is all the time that we
have today thank you very much to our
fellow our fellow pists for inspiring
sharing shall we give them another round
of applause please
thank we have reached the end of the PDA
2023 recipients Forum we hope that you
have enjoyed the Forum and Tak taken
away insightful points from our panel of
PDA 2023 recipients may I request for
the audience to stay and take a group
photo and may I also invite the
panelists to take their seats um and
with the audience as well so that we can
take a group photo